now what I've done for these are these
seven properties is I've given them all
names the reason why is because I did
used to in the past um i have taught
them as i have taught them as a
disconnected list of uh just algebra you
don't just here you go here's a whole
bunch of notation but i find it very hot
number one I find very hot remember
number two it's very hard to understand
what they mean without giving something
like a brief summary now these names are
not official at all if that for some of
them I will even like you'll be like a
serious that's a name and i'll even
quote marks around it but hopefully
it'll be just about your health remember
what these actually need okay so what
we'll start with is um we'll start with
three simple ones which you guys already
know they come from the 22 and extension
1 courses but they import format a very
important foundation for the other ones
which are a little bit hard ok so i call
these three one two three the reverse
property the w property and the symmetry
properties ok the reverse property the
double copy is a symmetry properties
because there's two of them so the
reverse property talks about when you
have a definite interval so where these
are all that definitely feels they're
all that way you've got some boundaries
you're thinking about areas the reverse
probably talked about when you integrate
of that interval but you integrate it in
reverse okay so rather than going from a
small value into a big value what
happens if you go from the V go to a
small value so if I say from A to B and
you've got some kind of function right
and I compare that to what happens if I
go rather than from A to B from B to a
it's same same interview and everything
right what is the relationship between
these two okay that you you might
actually do what this is but quickly and
I'm not going to cloud our working here
like with all of these proofs but just
so you can see the basic guts in how
this works okay if I were to say
evaluate this right hand side right so
this is not the order we're used to if
if is the smaller than a button B is the
bigger number ok so just off on the side
think about what would happen here
if you said the integral from B to a on
f of X right no no we don't know what
this song what's great is you do nothing
about it i'm just saying from eddie any
function you like so you're going to end
up with a primitive function which by
conventional usually call F prime
capital F right and you value me there
at the same boundaries right but you're
evaluating it in an unusual order ok now
just by definition of what a definite
integral here is what would the next
line be it'll be capital f the f prime
of your going to do the upper boundary
which in this case is the smaller number
right and then you're going to subtract
for you to the difference of the other
boundary which happens to be a bigger
one okay now what's weird about this is
like it connects to this in that it's
exactly the same but it's well it's it
reflects isn't it right like we would
say if i SAT that minus sign at the
front then good one this guy's going to
come out the front he's going to be
positive take away this guy right and
that's what we used to see when we
integrate normally right you've got the
upper boundary which is the big number
take away the smaller battery so that
makes sense right so therefore there
good morning therefore the relationship
between these this is the relationship
of negatives right if you integrate over
an interval doing reverse instead of
going from small to big you don't be too
small everything is turning to the exact
negative okay so you can see why I call
this the reverse property because you're
doing it the reverse the dummy popping
again one that we're very very limit if
you have any turn off right from A to B
this this variable of integration that
you're choosing here because it's a
definite integral it's just standing in
temporarily it's going to get replaced
by A's and B's as
you've actually finished the actual work
of integrating right there for being at
the X is just standing in you can put
anything in its place you can call that
anything you like right so you can say f
of T DT just have a different function
and integrate with respect to a
different variable doesn't matter you're
calling it t.t is just a temporary
double variable a label that you
promised you can have anything you like
we've seen after view we've seen ever
fina whatever very we've got there it's
just standing in for the time being
until your actual boundaries can pop it
okay so I've ones walk of it but these
are the kinds of things we're talking
about what do you think this is about 30
functions and symmetry and the fact that
our children wedding it already is okay
very good so we're talking about a lot
of even symmetry now these are mainly
talking about when you have symmetrical
boundaries right so symmetrical
symmetrical functions audit even
symmetrical boundaries negative add to a
now depending on whether you are odd or
whether you're even you will get one or
two different things if you're going for
me to pay to air let's think about for
the odd case first if you're the odd
case and we're thinking about you know
the controller's PV that something like
whatever he's a known function ok that's
what's that X cubed by this X or
something like that okay because odd and
you integrate from the same distance
over this side to that side for example
go from negative 1 to 1 what's going to
happen when you evaluate that integral
you just catira because you've got a
negative and a positive or a positive
and negative whatever you get if it's
all you'll get zero on the other hand if
F is even right and you don't need me to
draw an even function for you
demonstrate this everybody you've got
the same both positive or both negative
areas on either side because you've got
reflection symmetry right so instead of
getting
and canceling out how I'm going to
articulate this yeah okay too so I'm
gonna double right rather than from
negative a to a you just go halfway half
of that ballot half of that interval
which is not to a I suppose you could
also say negative a 20 those would be
the same thing but this is probably
easier because everything stays positive
so you're going to get double of that
integral provided F is it right now like
I said these are all pretty standard
actually standard exactly what they are
and these these all fit in the tuna and
extension one crosses they don't come up
very frequently which is why we're
dealing with the now but a tune in the
extension one students we can understand